I think both success and failure come
quite easy it's like it's weird because
I think when you because my I've been
very successful with the writing and
just because like you know the first
book so I've got there's a possum the
first book was the first thing I've
written and transporting it it got
published by the first publisher
assented to got you know and it became a
best-seller became a successful play got
made it a huge problem and it kind of
went around the world you know so it's
almost like the the kind of the dream
model to Kansas to launch arc in the
writing career really and so has been
successful but it's like it's only I
mean most of most of things I've done a
bit of failure to you know so it's like
I've kind of see I see that if you I
mean I mean I think from the outside
it's your people who see it as being
successful but on this you are see the
failures that I've had in life you know
I mean I feel that music and not being
able to do that to the extent that I
wanted to and I've been a failure a lot
of things like kind of like cut like
jobs are hard I mean I be able to I've
always been able to to act like somebody
who was successful doing that job with
act but it's always been front basically
and it almost been almost felt just that
much away from kind of being so voted or
discovered as a waster basically and
that kind of thing so I felt I felt a
lot of I felt a lot of failure and so
that in the past in no way I felt I've
been successful there's been writing and
it's just been by a series of kind of a
default thing really having failed
everything else